Tenía que decidir
si quería compartir solo las partes buenas de mi vida,
ya saben, como las que mostramos en redes sociales
que nos hacen parecer perfectos,
o si quería mostrarme vulnerable
y ser un libro abierto?
La decisión fue muy fácil.
Para marcar la diferencia en la vida de un niño,
tenía que ser transparente.
Así que me comprometí a contar mi historia personal.
Y esta historia está llena de personas que me amaron
me cuidaron y me hicieron crecer.
Y me ayudaron a sobreponerme y a sanar.
Y ahora es mi turno de ayudar a los demás a hacer lo mismo.
Cuando comencé la escuela yo era una niña de lo más normal.
Venía de una buena familia,
siempre me vestía bien,
siempre tenía una sonrisa en los labios,
y estaba preparada para la escuela.
Pero mi vida no era para nada normal.
En esa época, ya había sido víctima de abuso sexual.
Y aún seguía sucediendo.
Mis padres no lo sabían,
y yo no se lo había dicho a nadie.
Cuando comencé a ir a la escuela sentí que allí tendría yo un lugar seguro.
Así que estaba emocionada.
Imaginen mi angustia cuando conocí a mi profesor,
el profesor Randolph.
Este profesor no era quien abusaba de mí,
pero sí la personificación
de todo lo que más me asustaba en la vida.
Ya había empezado a usar mis mecanismos de defensa
tales como alejarme de situaciones que me llevaran a estar a solas con un hombre.
Y la situación era que, como alumna,
iba a estar en el aula con un hombre todos los días,
durante todo el año escolar.
Estaba asustada; no confiaba en él.
Pero, ¿saben qué?
el profesor Randolph resultó ser mi mayor defensor.
Pero al principio,
me aseguré de hacerle saber que él no me agradaba.
No estaba conforme;
era la niña que estaba desconectada.
También era difícil para mis padres.
No quería ir a la escuela,
así que peleaba con ellos cada mañana antes de subir al autobús.
No podía dormir por la noche ,
porque tenía demasiada ansiedad.
Así que iba a clases exhausta.
Y un niño cansado es un niño de mal humor,
a los que no se les puede enseñar con facilidad,
ya lo saben.
El profesor Randolph podría haberse acercado con frustración,
como lo hacen tantos profesores con niños como yo.
Pero él era diferente.
Él se acercó con empatía
y flexibilidad.
Me sentí muy agradecida.
El vio que esta niña de seis años estaba cansada y agotada.
Así que, en vez de hacerme salir afuera durante el recreo,
me dejaba quedarme y hacer una siesta,
porque él sabía que necesitaba descanzar.
Durante el almuerzo, en vez de sentarse con los demás profesores,
se sentaba en la mesa con los alumnos.
Nos hacía entablar conversación entre todos.
Y ahora que miro hacia atrás, puedo saber
que todo eso tenía un propósito,
él escuchaba y hacía preguntas.
Necesitaba saber qué era lo que estaba pasando.
Él construyó una relación conmigo.
Se ganó mi confianza.
Y lento pero seguro,
esas paredes que había levantado a mi alrededor
comenzaron a derrumbarse,
y, finalmente, me di cuenta que él era un buen tipo.
Sé que sintió como si no fuera suficiente.
Porque dio el primer paso y fue a hablar con mi madre.
Y logró que mi madre me diera permiso
para comenzar a hablar con la consejera estudiantil,
la señora McFadyen.
Comencé a verla una o dos veces por semana
durante los dos años siguientes.
Fue todo un proceso.
Durante ese tiempo,
nunca le revelé lo del abuso,
porque era un secreto;
Se suponía que no debía decirlo.
Pero ella unió los cabos sueltos, lo sé,
porque todo lo que hacía
era para empoderarme y ayudarme a encontrar mi voz.
Me enseñó a usar imágenes mentales
para superar mis miedos.
Me enseñó técnicas de respiración
para atravesar los ataques de ansiedad
que sufría con frecuencia.
Y hacíamos juegos de roles.
Ella se aseguró
de que yo pudiera defenderme ante cualquier situación.
Y llegó el día
en el que estuve en la misma habitación con mi abusador
y otro adulto.
Y conté mi verdad.
Hablé del abuso que sufrí.
Inmediatamente, mi abusador empezó a negarlo todo,
y la persona a quien le conté mi verdad,
no estaba capacitada para manejar semejante revelación
que acababa de lanzar.
Era más fácil creer al abusador
antes que a una niña.
Así que me dijeron que nunca volviera a mencionarlo.
De nuevo me hicieron creer que yo había hecho algo malo.
Fue devastador.
Pero, ¿saben qué?
algo bueno resultó de ese día.
Mi abusador supo que ya no iba a quedarme callada.
El poder cambió de manos.
Y los abusos pararon.
(Aplausos)
Pero la vergüenza
y el miedo de que pasé otra vez
seguió presente.
Y se mantuvo conmigo
durante muchos años más.
El profesor Randolph y la señora McFadyen,
me ayudaron a encontrar mi voz.
Me ayudaron a encontrar la luz.
Pero, ¿saben qué?
hay tantos niños que no tienen la misma suerte que yo.
Y pueden ser sus propios alumnos.
Por eso es tan importante para mí, venir a hablar aquí con Uds.,
para que puedan estar al tanto
y puedan empezar a hacer las preguntas difíciles
y presten atención a esos alumnos,
para que Uds. también puedan ayudarles a encontrar su camino.
Como maestra de jardín de infantes,
siempre empiezo el año escolar,
haciendo que mis alumnos confeccionen cajas sobre sus vidas.
Aquí hay dos de mis alumnos.
Y los incentivo
a que llenen sus cajas con cosas que los identifican
cosas sobre su vida,
lo que ellos consideren importante.
Las decoran a su gusto,
y se toman su tiempo para hacerlo,
ponen fotos de su familia y de sus mascotas,
y luego las presentan para mí y para sus compañeros.
Y en ese momento los escucho con mucha atención.
Porque todo lo que dicen,
sus expresiones faciales,
las cosas que no dicen
pueden ser señales de alerta para mí
y me pueden ayudar a descubrir cuáles son sus necesidades.
¿Qué es lo que los lleva
a tener el comportamiento que tienen en clase?
¿Cómo puedo ser mejor maestra
escuchando con atención todo lo que dicen?
También me hago un tiempo para desarrollar mi relación con ellos,
como el profesor Randolph hacía conmigo.
Me siento con ellos durante el almuerzo,
converso con ellos en los recreos,
voy a sus juegos los fines de semana,
voy a sus bailes.
Me vuelvo parte de sus vidas.
Porque para conocer de verdad a tus alumnos,
tienes que involucrarte en sus vidas.
Sé que algunos de Uds. son maestros de primaria
y de secundaria,
y quizá piensen que sus alumnos
ya se han casi desarrollado, pero
ellos solo están en piloto automático.
No se dejen engañar.
En especial con aquellos niños que parecen tenerlo todo bajo control
porque esos son los que más podrían necesitarlos.
Si Uds. vieran mi anuario escolar,
me verían en cada página
porque hacía de todo.
Incluso conduje el autobús escolar.
(Risas)
Yo era esa niña
sobre la que los profesores creían que era una alumna sobresaliente,
alguien popular,
que tenía todo bajo control en su vida.
Pero estaba perdida.
Estaba perdida,
y quería que alguien me preguntara:
"Lisa, ¿por qué estás aquí todo el tiempo?
¿por qué haces tantas cosas todo el tiempo?"
¿Alguna vez se preguntaron
si yo estaba huyendo de alguien,
o si estaba huyendo de algo?
¿Por qué no quería estar en mi vecindario
o en mi casa?
¿Por qué quería estar todo el tiempo en la escuela?
Eso nunca nadie lo preguntó.
No se confundan,
esto no quiere decir que todos los alumnos sobresalientes
sean víctimas de algún tipo de abuso o trauma.
Pero quiero que se tomen el tiempo de ser curiosos.
Pregunten ¿por qué?
Puede que descubran que hay una razón detrás de eso.
Uds. podrían ser la razón para estos niños puedan avanzar
con su historia.
Tengan cuidado de no asumir
que ya conocen cómo termina la historia.
No pongan un punto final donde debería haber un punto seguido.
Dejen que la historia continúe
y ayúdenles a saber que si les pasó algo traumático,
aun así vale la pena contar su vida.
Vale la pena contar su historia.
Para que podamos hacer esto,
creo que debemos aceptar nuestras historias personales como educadores.
Muchos de Uds. aquí sentados
pueden estar pensando
que eso también les pasó a Uds.,
pero no están listos para compartirlo.
Y eso está bien.
Ya llegará el momento
en el que sientan en su interior
que es momento de transformar ese dolor del pasado
en algún propósito para el futuro.
Estos niños son nuestro futuro.
Quiero incentivarlos a que se tomen un día cada vez.
Hablen con alguien.
Estén dispuestos y abiertos.
Mi historia cerró un ciclo
en la primavera del 2018,
cuando me invitaron a dar una charla
a un grupo de maestros y mentores principiantes.
Les compartí mi historia como lo estoy haciendo ahora,
y al finalizar una joven se acercó a mí.
Tenía lágrimas en los ojos y en voz baja me dijo: "Gracias".
"Gracias por compartir".
"No puedo esperar a decirle a mi padre
todo lo que he escuchado hoy".
Debió verme algo desconcertada,
porque luego me dijo:
"El profesor Randolph es mi padre".
Público: Ahhh
Y él a veces se pregunta,
si es que marcó la diferencia.
Hoy puedo llegar a casa y decirle que sí,
que definitivamente marcó la diferencia.
¡Qué regalo!
Y eso me llevó
a contactar a la hija de la señora McFadyen también,
y compartir con ella
el impacto que ella dejó en mí.
Y también quería hacerle saber
que yo he abogado para que haya más fondos
para consejeros estudiantiles, para trabajadores sociales escolares,
para psicólogos, enfermeras,
porque son fundamentales para la salud física y mental
de nuestros hijos.
Estoy muy agradecida con la señora McFadyen.
(Aplausos)
Una vez escuché a alguien decir
que para encontrar el modo de salir de la oscuridad
tienes que encontrar la luz.
Hoy espero que se vayan de aquí
y busquen oportunidades para ser esa luz.
No solo para los alumnos
sino también para los adultos,
en sus escuelas y en sus vecindarios.
Tienen ese don
de ayudar a alguien a navegar
a través de su trauma
y hacer que valga la pena contar su historia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)